el regreso al poder del grupo talibán en
afganistán ha despertado temor por la
implementación de una versión extrema de
la ley islámica cientos de afganos han
llegado al aeropuerto de la capital en
un intento por huir del país en alguno
de los vuelos de evacuación el fin de
semana un grupo de familias afganas
logró llegar a las afueras de washington
funcionarios estadounidenses aseguraron
que tres bases militares están listas
para albergar hasta 22 mil afganos por
su parte reino unido espera recibir unos
20.000 de ellos aunque no aseguran que
logren evacuar a todos absolutamente
nadie lamentablemente puede decir frente
a una cámara de televisión que podremos
evacuar los a todos la dura realidad de
situaciones complejas caóticas y
peligrosas como esta es que puede que
simplemente este no sea el caso
canadá se ha sumado al plan dando
prioridad a las minorías y personas de
la comunidad lgbt
representantes de la unión europea
visitaron el fin de semana junto con el
presidente del gobierno español un
centro que recibirá a refugiados afganos
con capacidad para mil personas la
estadía será temporal ya que luego serán
enviados a diferentes países del bloque
comunitario decenas de ellos ya han
llegado a francia y alemania- en américa
latina los gobiernos de brasil chile
costa rica méxico y colombia también han
abierto sus puertas
[Música]
generalmente se sientan a gears se
sientan de bailar o en realidad el debut
ante el temor de una ola migratoria
proveniente de afganistán
grecia construyó una valla fronteriza
con turquía de 40 kilómetros de largo lo
mismo hizo ankara que levantó un muro en
su frontera con irán con el fin de
evitar el paso de los migrantes